So, as researchers,...
...something we often do is use immense resources to achieve certain capabilities...
...or achieve certain goals...
...and this is essential to the progress of science or exploration of what is possible.
But it sorta creates this unfortunate situation...
...where a tiny, tiny fraction of the world...
...can actually participate in this exploration...
...or can benefit from that technology.
And something that motivates me, and what gets me really excited about my research...
...is when I see simple opportunities to drastically change that distribution,...
...and then, make the technology accessible to a much wider percentage of the population.
And I'm gonna show you two videos that have gotten a lot of attention recently...
...that I think embody this philosophy.
And they actually use the Nintendo Wii remote.
Now, for those of you who aren't familiar with this device,...
...it's a 40-dollar video game controller...
...and it's mostly advertised for its motion sensing capabilities,...
...so you can swing a tennis racket or hit a baseball bat.
But what actually interests me a lot more is the fact that in the tip of each controller...
...is a relatively high-performing infrared camera,...
...and I'm gonna show you two demos of why this is useful.
So, here I have my computer setup with the projector...
...and I have a Wii remote sitting on top of it.
And if for example, if you're in a school that doesn't have a lot of money,...
...which is probably a lot of schools...
...or if you're in an office environment, and you want an interactive whiteboard,...
...normally, this costs about two to three thousand dollars.
So, what I'm going to show you how to do is how to create one with a Wii remote.
Now, this requires another piece of hardware, which is this infrared pen.
You can probably make this yourself for about five dollars with a quick trip to the Radio Shack.
It's essentially got a battery, a button and an infrared LED,...
...and it turns on, you guys can't see it but it turns on whenever I push the button.
Now, what this means is that if I run this piece of software,...
...I can now register,...
...the camera sees the infrared dot...
...and I can register the location of the camera pixels to the projector pixels,...
...and now, this is an interactive whiteboard surface.
So, for about 50 dollars of hardware, you can have your own whiteboard.
This is Adobe Photoshop.
Thank you.